so here are the answers a package
delivery service sounds like a pool cue
because each package is probably
delivered by independent workers that
can pull tasks from the queue what about
checking in for a flight well I would
like to know that I'm ticked in and in
that case it's neither a push Q nor a
pool cue then the confirmation would be
delivered as part of the HTTP response
even if it takes a little bit of time
this is a situation very similar to when
you buy things using a credit card on
the internet where you also often wait
for the response what about code review
when a code review sounds like a pool
cue because you probably have many
people that can review the code so the
first one that's available can pull the
code review from the queue and then
batch processing of images which sounds
like a push q this is because your code
is probably doing the processing of the
images therefore you want to have
control over the execution